As hundreds of millions of people around the
globe get in their vehicles every day the absolute
last thing that anyone wants is to get in a car
crash. Unfortunately reality strikes and there
are millions of crashes around the globe every
day. These are stressful dangerous and extremely
costly in fact according to the association for
safe international road travel countries can pay
up to two to eight percent of their entire GDP on
the cost of crashes. So here's a business question
how can a modern insurance company step in
leverage data in AI and help alleviate some of the
time and stressors that their customers are paying
on all of these crashes. Let's say Caitlyn has
just been in an accident the last thing she wants
to worry about is a month-long claims process with
her insurance company. Luckily her insurer has an
automated claims processing workflow established
on their back end which means just minutes after
she's been rear-ended she's able to provide
some basic information to get the claims process
going. Another advantage is she's able to gather
and input the responsible parties information on
the spot without having to track him down later
leveraging her smartphone's camera she can
quickly document the damages and then select
the local shop she'd like the repairs done at. The
last step is to have the insurer call her an Uber
so that she can continue about her day crashes
are not fun although insurers today have the
ability to make the impact they have on their
customers less stressful and they do this by
ensuring that they have complete mastery of how
all of their data interacts with their customers.
And their customers experience with IBM
insurers can deliver modern customer
experiences like this example through a hybrid
cloud and AI platform deployable anywhere.
To dive deeper check out the linked videos and
ensure to like and subscribe to stay up to date.